hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math leader
to help you boost your score in your
math class improve your understanding
and hopefully make learning math a lot
less stressful so what we're going to
talk about in this video this is a
continuation of the previous video where
we talked about the locus okay of points
and a plane in this video we're gonna
talk about the locus of points in space
and three-dimensional space and we're
gonna go through some similar examples
but this is just going to be the 3d
version so let's get right into this
video so the first thing you want to
talk about okay are what are locus okay
what are lo silo site plural right it
what they are it's that they're the set
of points that satisfy some given
restrictions or requirements and so what
you want to do is you want to start off
by finding one point that satisfies
those restrictions and then find some
additional points build on that pattern
until you can find the entire set of
points that's the locus or the low C
okay if you plural of points that
satisfy that those given conditions so
let's take a look at some examples
you'll see what I mean so this first
example find the locus of points that
are three inches from a I'm going to
change this to a sphere okay of radius 5
inches so say for example you have a
sphere okay and the radius here is 5
inches like that and you want to find a
set of points that are three inches okay
from that sphere well you can see like
if you all the points on the sphere this
ball basically if you were to go three
inches out from there okay there is a
point three inches out from there there
is a point there is a point there is a
point there is a point so you're
starting to establish a pattern you can
see it's a sphere that's surrounding
okay the original sphere and it's three
inches out from there so I'm gonna try
to draw that here a three dimensional
diagram here in our two-dimensional
whiteboard okay like this okay so you
can see it's like surrounding it but
then what you might also think is say
well what happens if I pick maybe a
point inside the given sphere like that
or like that or like that and so what
ends up happening here is we get another
sphere okay
that's inside okay the given sphere
and now this one's only going to have a
radius of two inches so the outer one
has a radius of eight inches and the
inner sphere has a radius of just two
inches and so what you have is you have
concentric spheres meaning they have the
same Center and ones inside ones outside
so that's your solution set you just
describe that in words and you got it so
let's go on to the next one
find the locus of points that are 2
centimeters from a given line now keep
in mind in this video we're talking
about in three-dimensional space ok you
can do this in a plane but we're gonna
do this in space so let's draw that
given line okay there's a line right
there let's start with one point okay
that satisfies the given requirements
it's 2 centimeters away and then you
might notice a little down here it's
also 2 centimeters away and over here
it's 2 centimeters away but also since
we're doing three-dimensional space I
could come out from the board like this
that's 2 centimeters away or go to
centimeters behind the board and so what
you recognize that this is actually okay
a cylinder okay so I can draw that here
for us like this dot dot dot dot dot
okay and this one has a radius of 2
centimeters so basically the given line
is going right down the center of the
cylinder and the cylinder has a radius
of 2 centimeters so if you can visualize
that in three dimensions it keeps
extending in both directions so that's
the set of points ok locus just means a
set of points okay to satisfy that
requirement so we've got it let's go to
the next one two more examples and I
think you'll have it down find the locus
of points that are equidistant from two
points now remember we're thinking three
dimensional we're thinking of in space
here so let's draw the two given points
I'll just draw them with X's this time
let's find one point that satisfies the
requirement the most obvious one is the
midpoint right that's equidistant and
maybe this point over here and maybe
this point over here and maybe you this
point over here and then maybe you start
thinking well what about over here okay
that's the same distance okay and so
what we end up getting here is we end up
getting a plane like that so the plane
is gonna be
okay look going just like that so it's
basically it's you take the line that
connects the two given points and you
draw a plane that goes through the
midpoint and it's perpendicular to that
line that connects the two given points
so that's the plane that's all the
points in the plane in this
three-dimensional space will satisfy
that requirement so whether you go to
here to here or out to here they're all
going to be the same distance from the
given points okay last example find the
set of points notice I didn't even say
locus this time because I get so used to
thinking of the set of points when I see
the word locus that are equidistant from
three nine collinear points now if you
saw the last video you saw how I took
those three points and I made them into
a like a triangle and I thought of the
three points as like the vertices of a
triangle right so what you want to do is
you want to find the circumcenter the
circumcenter is going to be the point
okay that's equidistant from each of the
three given points gave these three
points right here and that circumcenter
is if you were to draw a circle around
or about the triangle okay such that the
vertices lie on the circle that point
okay it's going to be equidistant
because these are the radii of the
circle okay with me so far and but now
we're doing this in three-dimensional
space so you could think of this as well
as actually like up like I I'm gonna
draw this kind of like as a cylinder
like this kind of like that second
problem we did over here but what you
can do is you can think of this as a
line like this okay going right through
the circumcenter okay and it's gonna be
perpendicular to that circle okay so
that was a little bit more challenging
problem but again what you want to do is
you want to start off with one point
that satisfies the given requirements
then find two three four until you can
establish a pattern and then you know
you can just take it from there
so I hope this helps you to understand
how to do these locus or low-side
problems better subscribe to the channel
check out some of my other past videos
and I look forward to seeing in the
future ones I'll talk to you soon